because i'm going off the grid today we
planned and plotted
and arranged everything that my new book
could be announced
for pre-sale today so my new book
are we going to show it i'm going to i'm
going to there we go there's an image
my new book don't burn this country is
available for pre-sale now
yesterday we were uh on locals we had a
couple people guessing what the title
might be we said don't burn then people
had to guess people thought this
constitution
you know some other stuff this youtuber
etc etc uh but my new book don't burn
this country surviving and thriving in
our woke dystopia
is up for pre-sale today so what i'm
doing today
the book will be out on april 12 2022
the publishing world is just sort of
a slow slog we still have a little bit
of editing we're going to do
i actually i'm going to change the intro
to the book to talk about what happened
on twitter because it's
it's a perfect example of exactly what
this book is about
but what we're doing today is i want to
sign book plates for every
single copy bought today
if i have to go off the grid with a
crippled hand if my hand at the end of
the day
i got like the claw hand i will be happy
to do it if we sell 10 000 copies today
i will spend the rest of my day going
through my sharpies
and signing book plates so you can buy
the book right now for pre-sale
at don'tburnthiscountry.com that's gonna
direct you to the penguin site where you
can pick which retailer so you can do
amazon obviously barnes and noble et
cetera et cetera
and then we've got a little form which
is in this youtube description right now
and all you got to do is fill that out
show us that you bought the book and i
will sign
the book plate for you today
and our locals members as you guys know
because i did a live stream
uh exclusive to you guys this morning uh
locals members are getting signed and
numbered copies
so anyone that joins locals today i will
also i can do a signed and numbered copy
so this is the book plate
these are numbered down here but if you
don't want to join us on locals
you're a loss however don't burn this uh
don't burn this country
you go to don't burn this book.com too i
think there's something going on over
there buy that one it's pretty good
but don't burn this country.com buy the
book
and then i want to sign as many as i as
i can today and i'm incredibly excited
to be uh
sharing this book with you guys and as i
said i'll make a few little changes and
i want to change something at the
at the top right now just because of
what happened here um but it really
is the next step in some ways i now
see don't burn this thing
as a trilogy right so we had don't burn
this book don't burn this country
what could be the next one but i really
am seeing it as a trilogy now because in
don't burn this book what i did
was lay out what my beliefs are i
believe and i still believe this to this
day
that my classically liberal principles
the idea
of individual rights and logic and
reason and limited government and
laissez-faire economics what are thought
of really as modern conservative
principles
because i also talk about uh why belief
is important
as an under guard for all of those
things
um that is the right lens to look at a
free society through
and to build a free society this book is
about the things that you can do
to make sure as the as the subtitle says
that you can not only survive but thrive
i want people to survive and thrive
not just survive these lockdowns and
mass mandates and getting jabbed and
being lied to all the time
i want you to thrive in it because i've
managed to thrive thankfully
but it's not by accident maybe it's with
a little bit of luck but it's because i
navigated this thing properly i made the
right business
decisions i i took risks and that really
is what this book is about being less
reliant on the system being less reliant
on big tech on big government
on big pharma all of those things that
really is what this is all about